good evening everyone and welcome to the
Smithsonian associates lecture the Big
Bang what it was and why we believe it
happened on Pam Wayman from the
Smithsonian associates is this evenings
speaker we are honored to have dr. Simon
Singh back at the Smithsonian for the
third time dr. Singh reserved has
received his PhD in particle physics
from Cambridge he then spent two years
at the European Centre for particle
physics in Geneva and published several
scientific papers after leaving this
field he taught mathematics and science
at schools in India and South Africa and
eventually returned to London in 1990 to
join the BBC science department for five
years he worked on the popular science
programme tomorrow's world in 1997 he
directed the Emmy nominated documentary
Fermat's Last Theorem
as part of the Nova series he also wrote
a book by the same title which was a
runaway bestseller along with his
subsequent book several years later the
code book
he's just released publication The Big
Bang is the subject of tonight's lecture
and is available for sale and signing
after the program along with being an
author and TV producer dr. Singh is also
a freelance journalist and has written
for the New York Times and scientific
America among others as well as his
weekly column in the independent on
Sunday please join me in a warm welcome
back to the Smithsonian for dr. Simon
Singh
thank you very much for coming out this
evening on such a cold and sort of
awkward evening and it's great to be
back at the Smithsonian I'm going to
talk about the Big Bang it's a it's a
book that I started writing almost three
years ago and it was three years ago
that I came up with a title Big Bang and
it just seemed like the obvious title at
the time the only problem is that just
three months ago another book was
published with the identical title this
is my book Big Bang this is this is the
cover the other book Big Bang is this
one Big Bang the only sex manual you'll
ever need and I mentioned this just in
case there are people here under a
misapprehension because you're going to
be very very disappointed the point of
the point of writing this book is that
it suddenly struck me that that we're
the first generation of humans you know
ever since humans have looked up at the
stars we've wondered about the universe
and wondered where where the universe
came from but now we're the first
generation of humans where scientists
can give us a really good theory of the
universe a compelling convincing
consistent theory which has real
evidence to back it up and we call it
the Big Bang and I wanted to sort of
celebrate that there's lots about the
universe that we don't know but the Big
Bang really did happen and I wanted to
tell the story of who came up with the
idea of the Big Bang and how did the
establishment react how did the
Mavericks prove that the Big Bang
happened that really happened and why
today is it a more compelling theory
than ever before and that's what I'm
going to try and do this evening talk
about the Big Bang could also talk about
how science works more generally how new
ideas are adopted into science what's
known as sort of a paradigm shift and
I'm gonna try and get as far in the
story as the moment when the phrase Big
Bang was invented and I'll gloss over
lots of things and there are lots of
things I won't have time to cover but
hopefully in the question answers we
think we can cover some of those other
points and maybe I don't usually talk
about this part of a story but but but
but maybe just touched on it today
I'm gonna start the story in 1930 which
would you'll see in a minute but one of
the great things about science is you
have this this notion of one idea
building on another idea and then
somebody coming in from left field with
some new piece of technology that allows
astronomers to see something that
they've never seen before then that
contributes some other piece of the
great puzzle and and this is just one of
the great unsung heroes in in in
astronomy and perhaps slightly topical
this is a woman Henrietta Leavitt and
Henrietta Leavitt worked in Harvard in
1900 and at the time women were
forbidden from really doing astronomy
you weren't allowed to look through the
telescope it wasn't thought ladylike to
stay up late at night and stare at the
romantic moonlight with the men
so what Henrietta Leavitt was allowed to
do was study the photographs that were
taken at Harvard had this fantastic
program of photographing the entire sky
over 20 years they took about half a
million photographs and here you see an
army of women analyzing photographs
measuring each star its position its
brightness its color and they were known
as Pickering's harem
this is Edward Pickering on the left and
he employed them because they were
meticulous more meticulous than the men
and they were basically cheap they
tolerate half the pay that the men would
but these women were also extraordinary
bright and even though all they could do
is look at the data they discovered
things that the men had completely
overlooked we can zoom into that picture
on the back wall on the left you have
Henrietta Leavitt and the chart shows a
wave and undulating wave and that
represents the brightness of a type of
star known as a Cepheid variable Cepheid
variable as you might expect varies and
brightness it gets brighter and dimmer
and brighter and dimmer over the course
of a few nights or sometimes a few weeks
depending on the star what Henrietta
Leavitt did was she showed that you
could use that variation in brightness
the rate of variation to work at how
bright a Cepheid really is and if you
know how bright a Cepheid really is and
you can see how bright it appears to be
you can work out its distance so
Henrietta Leavitt deserves credit for
really working out how to
distances in the cosmos and as you'll
see later on measuring distances is
incredibly important in astronomy as you
might expect but she's just one of the
players who over the course of three
hundred years got us to the stage in
1930 when this gentleman sir James
Gene's wrote a book Sir James James
wanted to write a book to explain to the
public what cosmologists understood in
1930 his book was called the mysterious
universe it was aimed at a popular
audience and a lot of people read it
even Tallulah Bankhead the Hollywood
screen goddess read it she enjoyed it so
much that she said it contained what
every girl should know but having said
that it didn't mention anything about
the Big Bang Theory it talked about a
very different universe it talked about
a universe that had been here forever a
universe that had been here for eternity
and the universe that didn't change it
was the same yesterday as it would be
tomorrow
and that's what people understood about
the universe back in 1930 now the Big
Bang Theory talks about a completely
different type of universe the Big Bang
talks about a universe with a finite
history because it was created it's some
finite point in the past and it was hot
and dense and compact and it exploded
and it expanded outwards and it evolved
it changed it changed into the universe
we have today and it continues to change
into the future so the old view the 1930
view is of a steady eternal universe the
Big Bang Theory on the other hand is
about a dynamic created evolving
universe so the question is where did
the Big Bang idea come from well the
person who maybe deserves most credit is
George la Mettrie a Belgian cosmologists
and in 1927 he said according to the
laws of physics there is no reason why
the universe couldn't have been created
there's no reason why all the matter
couldn't have been compacted once into
what he called a primeval atom and that
primeval atom would have ruptured and
exploded just like some gigantic uranium
atom and in its nuclear fission it would
have
debri outwards in all directions and
that debris would have coagulated and
formed the stars and galaxies we see
today all he said was that the laws of
physics are compatible with that he
didn't call it the Big Bang Theory he
talked about a day without yesterday
it's a very poetic phrase but
essentially meaning the Big Bang Theory
as we know it today we think of things
slightly differently we don't think of
primeval atoms but it was important
because it talked about a theory of
creation immediately the establishment
reacted badly they said look the reason
you like the idea of a creation is
because you're a priest
Lamech I was a priest and a cosmologists
and when you talk about creation you're
trying to imply that there must have
been a creator and you're trying to
smuggle God into physics and so people
rejected this idea immediately the
metric countered the Metra said there
are two ways of arriving at the truth
and I decided to follow them both and by
that he meant the religion told him
about the spiritual world but science
told him about the material world and he
kept the two worlds very very separate
he didn't use his science to back up his
theology and he didn't use the Bible to
back up his science he said the reason I
believe in the Big Bang is because it's
a convincing scientific idea but as I
say the establishment reacted badly even
Albert Einstein when Albert Einstein
heard about Lemaitre said your
calculations are correct but your
physics is abominable and that's a fair
comment
you know maths a theoretical physics is
really maths and with maths you can play
games you can you can come up with any
kind of theory the important thing is
does your theory match reality as far as
Einstein was concerned there was no
evidence to back up the Metris theory so
at this stage it was just a silly
mathematical game and just to show you
the sort of absurd things you can do
with mathematics I'm just going to use
some mathematics now to prove to you
that the Teletubbies are evil I don't
know if you have the Teletubbies over
here they're a big thing in England a
children's sort of TV show and they go
around making silly noises and the BBC
put a lot of time and money into the
Teletubbies
so the Teletubbies can be said to be a
product of time and money
we also know very well that time is
money
so we can substitute back into the first
equation so that Teletubbies are money
times money or is mathematics we call
that money squared we also know very
well I think it's been said many times
that money is the root of all evil hence
money squared is evil and therefore the
Teletubbies are evil so I should stress
this is just a theory there's no
evidence to back this up
and that's what you need insight you
need evidence to back up the mathematics
now fortunately in in the 1920s
scientists were building bigger and
better telescopes than ever before
there's this wonderful thing that
science allows you to understand the
universe Newton studied light he led us
to a better understanding of optics and
how glass can bend light once you
understand the science you can build
technology you can build telescopes and
once you have technology that helps your
science because you can see better and
further than ever before and
particularly a Mount Wilson in Southern
California about 30 miles from LA the
Mount Wilson Observatory had the biggest
and best telescopes in the world and
they also had the best astronomers in
the world in particular there's a track
called Edwin Hubble his now-famous whose
name lives on because of the Hubble
Space Telescope the Hubble Space
Telescope was named after Edwin Hubble
because he was simply the greatest
astronomer of the first half of the 20th
century and Hubble wasn't just a great
intellect he was also very charismatic
he dominated the field with his
intellect and his personality and people
would come up to the mountain to visit
Hubble and hear him speak and to visit
the giant telescopes and his future wife
actually came on one of these tourist
trips to the mountain to look at the
telescopes and when she saw Hubble for
the first time she never forgot that
moment she was completely entranced by
this man and she later wrote down
her recollection of this moment Hubble
was stood there looking at a photograph
of the universe and she always
remembered that moment she described him
as an Olympian tall strong and beautiful
with the shoulders of the Hermes of
Praxiteles there was a sense of power
channeled and directed in an adventure
that had nothing to do with personal
ambition so she was clearly smitten by
him unfortunately she was married at the
time already and she was actually
married to a geologist which is never a
very pleasant thing but three weeks
later her husband fell down a mine shaft
and was killed so there was I was kind
of a happy ending there of sorts so
Hubble was was was this great astronomer
with great telescopes and he he wanted
to study the galaxies the earth goes
round the Sun the Sun is a star the
stars gather together in clusters or
groupings of billions of stars and
here's a typical galaxy and each galaxy
contains billions hundreds of billions
of stars and there are hundreds of
billions of galaxies now what Hubble
wanted to know was what do these
galaxies do do they just float around in
space doing nothing do they move
randomly do they move systematically
what are the dynamics of the cosmos are
there any motions that he could measure
and detect so how would he go about
measuring the motions of these galaxies
well all you all you can ever do as an
astronomer is look at these galaxies all
you can ever do is absorb the tiny
flakes of light that reach the earth and
what we know about light is that light
is a wave and here you see the spectrum
of light going from red to blue red
light is a wave blue light is a wave the
only difference is that red light is a
short wave and blue light is a long wave
and it's the length of the waves the
wavelength that tells you its color now
that's a really important thing to know
about light now all the galaxies should
look the same color but it's a kind of a
crude statement and maybe an
oversimplification but essentially
because the galaxies are made of all the
same stuff of hydrogen
helium they should all emit the same
distinct set of colors except for one
thing
Christian Doppler was a physicist and he
was interested in ways he was interested
in light waves and he was interested in
sine waves in this case a long sound
wave is a low pitch a short sound wave
is a high pitch and Doppler said look
here's an object and it's emitting sound
in fact I've got an object here if I
switch it on it's just a beeper
everybody everybody hears the same
beeping noise the same pitch because the
waves are emanating all directions
equally and if you look at the diagram
it's like something tapping the surface
of a pond and sending out ripples both
microphones on either side hear the same
noise the same pitch because the
wavelength reaching either side is
identical but if that object starts to
move now the objects now moving to the
right as it moves to the right the the
waves it's sending out in front of
itself start to cluster together whereas
the waves it sends out behind itself get
drawn apart so now something interesting
happens if you're a microphone on the
right you hear a higher pitch because
the waves are shorter if your microphone
on the left you hear a lower pitch
because the waves are longer so even if
you can't see the object but you can
hear it you can work at its direction of
motion towards you're away from you
depending on the pitch if it's moving
towards you it must be high pitch if
it's moving away from you
it's a low pitch and if you've ever seen
a fast car go by fast cars make that
sort of classic noise yeah they're from
a high pitch to a low pitch as they
approach and then recede and I think we
can try this side I don't know if it'll
work if I spin this beeper around my
head as it comes towards you you might
hear a higher pitch and as it goes away
from you might hear a lower pitch but
let's see if it works
because I'm in the Midlands it's not
towards me or away from me so I don't
hear the pitch but obviously most people
that could hear while snowing that known
as the Doppler shift and the Doppler
shift here's another way of visualizing
it here's an object sending out sound
waves as it moves to the right the sound
waves get squashed
now the same thing should happen with
light here's a galaxy and it's emitting
light and the galaxies moving it's
moving to the right and if you're on the
right of the galaxy then the waves will
get squashed and you'll see a short
wavelength if you're on the other side
of the galaxy the waves get stretched
and you'll see a longer wavelength now
longer wavelength is more towards a red
direction a shorter wavelength is near
to the blue direction so galaxies as I
said should look crudely the same color
but if the galaxy looked bluer than it
should that means it's coming towards
you if it's look if it looks redder than
it should it means it's moving away from
you and this is a really crucial point
it's sort of the most important bit of
physics in this talk it's known as the
redshift moving away blue shift moving
towards you and just to reiterate this
point because it's so important I'm
gonna play you a song
it's the cosmic Doppler song by the
chromatics it's the only a cappella song
about astrophysics that I know and
they're just gonna reiterate what I've
said they're going to talk about
redshifts and blueshifts and approaching
and receding they don't talk about
frequency rather than wavelength but
don't worry about that the important
point is what they're gonna say about
redshifts and blueshifts and stars and
galaxies the cosmic dr. song by the
chromatics here we go
and when it started raining
button button button button button
button button button but come back to my
job um there's one thing about that
video is if you've never heard of
redshift or blueshift before you'll
never ever forget about them again and
some so what happened when when Hubble
measured these galaxies what were their
colors here are three galaxies that
Hubble looked at and I've shown you the
distances already the distances are nine
billion billion kilometers 10 to the 18
means a billion billion and then at 220
and then twelve hundred billion billion
kilometres respectively and this is
where Levites work comes in Henrietta
Leavitt who we spoke about in the
beginning it was thanks to her Cepheid
variable measurements that Hubble was
able to measure these distances when he
looked at the colors of these galaxies
he looked at the first galaxies in first
clouds he was a little bit red little
bit red means it's moving away from us
and the amount of redness told us that
it was moving away at a speed of 6
billion kilometers a year the next one
was a little bit redder so it's moving
away even faster at 170 billion
kilometers a year third one even redder
still so it's moving away at an even
faster speed 730 billion kilometers a
year now if a plane could travel that
far seven hundred thirty billion
kilometers a year it would it would
cross Atlantic in just a couple of
seconds so these are phenomenally high
speeds but what's really important is
the direction of motion every single
galaxy is moving away from us all of the
remote galaxies that Hubble measured
were receding from the earth now that's
really interesting because that's
exactly what Lamech are predicted about
the Big Bang if the Big Bang happened
all this dense matter compacted into
this mother of all atoms explodes
outwards throws out this debris the
debris congeals and form stars and
planets those stars and planets should
still be receding and that's what Hubble
saw Hubble saw that indeed all the
galaxies are moving away from us
so this is the very first evidence that
backs up the Big Bang Theory as
described initially by la Mettrie and
moreover you can work out when the Big
Bang happened if we divide the distances
by the speed we can work out when those
galaxies were back here on top of the
earth
because when they were all back here in
one place presumably that's when the Big
Bang happened so we've got a galaxy
there it's been traveling at 6 billion
kilometers a year it's nine billion
billion kilometres away if it's
traveling at that speed and it's that
far away when was it back here or we
just divide the distance by the speed
nine divided by six is one point five so
that galaxy was back here 1.5 billion
years ago the other one divided to 20 by
one seventy it was back here 1.3 billion
years ago the third one was back here
1.6 billion years ago now allowing for
errors there's a tiny tiny red shifts
and tiny amounts of light allowing for
the errors that's an incredibly accurate
agreement it's really telling us that
between 1 & 2 billion years ago all the
matter in the universe was compacted
into one place I mean just a slight
detour here my first book was about
maths and in maths you have incredible
precision people get their numbers
accurate to n decimal places or they
have perfectly accurate results in
astronomy errors of a billion years here
or there are kind of ignored and that
story that illustrates this point
concerns a an astronomer and a physicist
and a mathematician who go on holiday to
Scotland and they crossed the border in
their train and they see a field
containing a black sheep and the
astronomer who is obviously a lot vaguer
than the physicist and the mathematician
says look all sheep and Scott lamaze be
black physicist is a bit more accurate
looked at this one black sheep and says
no no no all we can say is it's some
sheep in Scotland and the mathematician
looks at the other tuna shakes his head
and says no no no all we can truly say
accurately is that there exists in
Scotland at least one field containing
at least one sheep one side of which is
black so
so I mean a slightly unfair to
astronomers because these are incredibly
difficult measurements and as I said
when you get that kind of agreement it's
telling you that something big happened
one or two billion years ago so not only
do you have evidence for the Big Bang
you can actually begin to date it so
let's see where we are in 1927 George
Lemaitre came up with a Big Bang Theory
in 1929 Hubbell gives us some evidence
that kind of begins to prove the Big
Bang and yet in 1930 we started off with
Sir James Gene's writing a book called
mysterious universe where he doesn't
mention the Big Bang so how can how can
a respected cosmologist and in fact the
whole establishment talk about cosmology
and in all the Big Bang when the Big
Bang has a good theory and some good
evidence to support it whether two
reasons that I'm gonna cover that sort
of explain what happened here first of
all the date Hubble's data implied that
the universe was just 1 or 2 billion
years old those numbers I showed you 1.3
1.5 1.6 imply that the universes is
young just just a couple of billion
years old geologists already knew that
the earth was 3 billion years old and
that's clearly absurd the earth date is
very accurately known and very reliable
and and a minimum of three and a half
billion years and so how can the earth
be older than the universe that's what
critics of the Big Bang said they said
the Big Bang Theory is is absurd because
it predicts such a young universe today
we know the universe is actually much
older than that and that problems gone
away but it took a long time for that
problem to go away a more general
problem I'll explain what this problem
is in a second but before I explain the
problem I just want to do a little
demonstration to explain the effect
which might may not make sense at first
but let me do the demonstration and
you'll see what I'm getting at I'm gonna
play you a little bit of music I'm gonna
pay you some stairway to heaven by Led
Zeppelin here we go
don't be long
so that's stairway to heaven by Led
Zeppelin I'm now gonna play you that
same song but I'm gonna play it to you
backwards and I just want you to have a
listen to this it's gonna sound like
gobbledygook but I just want to see if
you can hear anything when Led
Zeppelin's Stairway Zevon's play
backwards here we go
right now just just kind of interested
anybody here the word Satan hands up
hands up all right I reckon that maybe
about 1 in 10 people heard the word
Satan okay that's good I'm hands up who
heard the words here's to my sweet Satan
the one whose little path would make me
sad whose power is Satan oh he'll give
you he'll give you 666 there was a
little tool shed where he made us suffer
Oh sad Satan hands up anybody just put
your hands hot huh just mean just me and
you right okay um I'm gonna play that
bit of music again and this time I
promise you that you will also hear
those words okay I promise you you will
hear those words and I also promise you
that I haven't changed the music I'm
gonna play you stairway to heaven Led
Zeppelin backwards and it's the
identical piece of reverse music that
you've just heard
I haven't tampered with it or tinkered
with it in any way whatsoever and yet
this time you will hear all of those
words here we go Led Zeppelin's Stairway
to Heaven backwards except this time
you're gonna hear what I've heard
- hands up whoo-hoo-hoo hurts most of
those words Oh God good good not not
just me though that's a relief I mean I
love doing this just I think it's
extraordinary the effect this is you
know one minute you hear nothing and
next minute you kind of hear everything
in the context of the Big Bang what
happened there was that there's clearly
nothing there if you play music
backwards
it's gobbledygook and you don't hear
anything and the first time you listen
to it you pretty much heard nothing and
that's the way it is but the second time
I said to you you will hear these words
and I showed you some words and I primed
you and you then probably want to hear
the words and there is a vague vague
vague resemblance to these words but
more importantly your brain is fantastic
at finding patterns visual patterns
speech patterns patterns of every kind
and you've spent so much of your life in
kind of noisy bars or or half hearing
conversations that your brain is great
at making sense of things that are
supposed to make sense so when I say
this is supposed to make sense you begin
to hear those words even though they're
clearly not there so your five senses
can sometimes make you see and hear
things that just aren't there and that
can sometimes happen in science
especially when the data is poor in this
auditorium we've got very good speakers
a very good sound system but if I do
this demonstration with very small tinny
speakers it's actually even better
effect because your brain does even more
processing and it sees even more of what
it wants to see and hear and that
happens in science as I say if you've
got very bad data then scientists can
look into that data and see what they
want so if you're a Big Bang theorist
and you look at Hubble's data you would
say our look that completely supports my
theory of the Big Bang Hubble's data
wasn't very good if you didn't believe
in the Big Bang you could look at
Hubble's data and say no no actually
doesn't mean anything to do with a big
bang it means that the universe has been
here forever
so because the data was bad scientists
could interpret
to favor their own biases and prejudices
and somebody who did just that was a a
chap called fritz Vicki Fritz Vicki was
an astrophysicist based in I think
Caltech and my favorite story about
Fritz Vicki I'll just tell you this very
briefly he came up with a wonderful
insult if he didn't like people he would
call them a spherical bastard and that's
because a sphere looks the same
whichever way you look at it and a
spherical bastard is someone who's a
bastard whichever way you look at them
so it's kind of gone down in folk
history and astrophysics for that
comment alone buts Vicki said you know
people said to spooky look the galaxies
are moving apart the universe is clearly
expanding and he said no no they're not
moving and they said look but they look
red and the recent they look red is
because they're moving away from us and
that's the Doppler shift so Vicki said
no no the reason they look red is that
the galaxies emit light the light gets
scattered by dust and gas interstellar
dust and gas and when light gets
scattered it loses energy and when light
loses energy it turns red and that's a
perfectly valid chain of logic it's
called the tired light theory light
emitted get scattered gets tired loses
energy looks red so Vicki could look at
the same data and interpret it
differently so it fitted his prejudice
of a universe where the galaxies didn't
move where the galaxies were static
where the universe was eternal and here
are three other people who had a
prejudice that the universe have been
here forever and we all have prejudices
scientists are human and so they you
know they can't help but have their
biases and this is Thomas gold Hermann
Bondi and Fred Hoyle and their bias was
that the universe had been here forever
but their problem was that they if the
universe has been here forever that kind
of implies it doesn't change if it
changes it evolves and if it evolves and
it kind of must have started somewhere
but on the other hand the universe
clearly does change it clearly is
dynamic
so their problem was how can we have a
universe that changes but stays the same
besides absurd how can anything change
but stay the same but that's what they
wanted to do they wanted to find some
theory of cosmology that allowed for
change but allowed for things to say the
same and they got their inspiration for
finding a theory when they went to see a
film this is a British film called dead
of night it was released in 1945 and
it's the first horror film made after
the war during the war you couldn't make
horror films bad for morale straight off
the war ended this is the first British
horror film dead of night and it's the
story of a young man who's having a
wonderful dream
he's having this this deep dream and he
suddenly wakes up and he jumps out of
bed gets washed gets dressed jumps into
his car drives into the countryside his
car breaks down he goes into this house
the house is full of strangers he says
this is really weird
I've never met any of you before but I
recognize you because you were in the
dream I had last night and they're all a
bit puzzled and a bit perplexed and
suspicious but they're curious and
intrigued and they start telling the
stranger their own weird stories of
weird experiences that have happened to
them so the film is a series of little
short stories each one told by house
guests to this mysterious stranger who's
turned up at the door and when they've
told their stories they look at the
stranger and I started walking to Walton
and they grabbed him by the neck and
they begin to strangle him and they
begin to throttle him and just as he's
about to be throttled to death he wakes
up and it's all been a dream and he gets
washed gets dressed jumps in his car
drives into the countryside his car
breaks and he goes into a house the
house is full of strangers he said this
is really weird I've never met any of
you before but I recognize you from a
dream I just had last night so here is a
film that clearly changes it clearly
evolves it has plot development and
character development and yet it doesn't
change it comes back to the start and
the film could carry on for eternity
so Coyle and and bomb d and Gould said
you know can nature be like
and they came up with some really good
examples this picture shows a client
called a lenticular cloud and it sits on
the top of a mountain now on the top of
a mountain you have very strong winds
and the winds should blow the cloud away
and yet lenticular clouds sit there all
day they can sit there for hours and
hours on end even though there are very
very high winds this should blow them
away so what's happening is that let's
imagine the wind is blowing from left to
right as the wind blows up here air goes
up the mountain and freezes and adds to
the cloud at this end meanwhile this
cloud gets blown across on a kind of a
conveyor belt at this end these bits of
cloud go down the mountain they warm up
and they disappear so the process it's
happening here is that the wind blows
new stuff onto this end of the cloud and
it blows away old stuff from this end of
the cloud so after half an hour it's a
completely different cloud the cloud has
changed but it kind of stays the same as
humans we change and stay the same
millions of cells die every day but they
get replaced and apart from our brain
and our liver are for about six years
we're completely different people every
cell in our body has been replaced with
completely different people we've
changed and yet we're the same I still
feel that I'm me and you still feel that
you're you so things can change and they
can stay the same as a Hubble as our
Hoyle gold and Bondi try to invent a
cosmology a universe that changed but
stayed the same and this is what they
came up with I've got two diagrams here
the top one is a representation of the
Big Bang model and we'll look at that
one first each of these dots is a galaxy
as the universe expands the galaxies
move further and further apart and the
universe gets bigger and emptier and
more desolate in the steady state
universe which is what Hoyle gold and
Bondi proposed each of these dots is
still a galaxy
oh boy here we go each of these dots are
still a galaxy the universe expands but
this time new matter is created in
between the dots in between the galaxies
and those bits of new matter form little
baby universes here we go we can just
see the baby universes and then it's
universe expands even more the baby
universes grew up into big universes
bits are the baby galaxies grow up into
big galaxies and this patch of the
universe on the right looks pretty much
like the patch of universe on the left
it's bigger but if the universe is
infinite then twice infinity still
infinity so Hoyle gold and Bondi could
argue that here's a universe on the left
which can expand but it doesn't really
change it changes but pretty much stays
the same the galaxies move apart but new
matter fills in the gaps and keeps the
overall density of matter in the
universe and they called that the steady
state theory so the steady state Theory
allows for an expanding universe but it
also allows for eternity The Big Bang
Theory allows for an expanding universe
but it talks about a finite moment of
creation in the past so you have to
dramatically different views of the
universe
one of them is put forward by Fred Hoyle
the other is really fathered by George
Lemaitre
and that's the situation in the 1950s
you have two theories explaining the
same set of data and Hoyle was the
greatest critic of the Big Bang he hated
the Big Bang and yet he was the person
who actually named it he was giving a
radio lecture I think in 1950 on the BBC
and in that lecture he said there are
two theories of the universe there's my
theory of the steady state theory it's
great and then there's this horrible
other theory where things explode from
nothing and that's called some car nuts
he said you know it's just like some
kind of Big Bang and it's very
derogatory derisory offhand comment so
first time the phrase Big Bang was used
but the phrase stuck and ever since then
we've used the phrase Big Bang Calvin
and Hobbes the cartoon strip offered an
alternative
which physicists used for a while Calvin
once said to Hobbes Big Bang is not a
very magnificent name for such a grand
vision of the universe and Hobbes says
well what would you call it and Calvin
says I call it the horrendous space
kablooey and for for a while
physicists wrote papers about the
horrendous space kablooey or the HSK
theory of the universe but the Big Bang
is is is what we now call this theory
and the battle over the last 50 years
has been to decide which of these
theories is correct isn't the Big Bang
is it the steady state I I'm gonna sort
of wrap things up here but I'm going to
talk about one piece of evidence over
and over again is each decade passed
people discovered more evidence about
the universe and over and over again
that evidence back the Big Bang and at
one point I want to make before I come
to the evidence which is that I've given
you the impression that scientists have
prejudices and biases and and they're
human and they they sometimes make
mistakes and they see things in the data
which aren't necessarily there and
that's true if the data is bad the job
of good scientists is to find good data
the job of scientist is to find evidence
that nobody can argue with and that's
what happened between 1950 and 1990
people went out to look for data and
observations and did experiments that
show beyond all reasonable doubt which
theory was correct and that's the Big
Bang Theory
it doesn't matter how important you are
doesn't matter how much money you've got
it doesn't matter how beautiful your
theory is but if it doesn't match up
with observation it's not worth a thing
my favourite quote at the moment is by
the 19th century naturalist Thomas
Huxley and he said there's nothing more
tragic in science than the slaying of a
beautiful hypothesis by an ugly fact and
that that summarizes what science is all
about and in this case it didn't matter
how beautiful you thought the steady
state theory was at the end of the day
it was killed by ugly facts and and the
one I'm going to folk
a song actually now may be mentioned -
because we're here in Washington and
this is sort of a Washington story these
three gentlemen were physicists at
George Washington University Robert
Herman George gammaw and Ralph Alpher
and in the mid forties a particularly
gone off an alpha said look if there was
a big bang in the mid forties nobody
really knew whether there was or not
people said if there was a big bang
you'd start off with very hot dense
hydrogen hydrogen is the simplest
element in the universe number one in
the periodic table
everything would be hydrogen but in the
heat of the Big Bang the hydrogen would
fuse you'd have nuclear reactions and
hydrogen would fuse into helium and we
can work out exactly how much helium
there should be and they did their
calculations and their calculations
showed that if the Big Bang is correct
then the universe should be made of
three-quarters hydrogen one-quarter
helium and sure enough when you look up
at the universe that's what you see
three course of the universe is hydrogen
one quarter is helium the only way to
explain that is with the Big Bang Theory
what the Big Bang Theory has done there
is it's put his neck on the line and it
said look if the ratio fits what I
predict I may be right if it doesn't fit
what I predict then my theory must be
wrong and in this case the Big Bang
Theory was backed up by the observations
the story here very famous story is at
gamma off George gamma off and Ralph
alpha-alpha was the junior PhD student
and gamma
said to alpha and why don't we invite my
friend Hans bethe to be on the paper
because then it'll be authored by alpha
beta and gamma which is a nice pun
except that beta with a world famous
physicist gamma off was very famous and
poor and alpha was a junior PhD student
who'd made a brilliant contribution but
he was largely overlooked because these
other two names on the paper really
dwarfed him and the double injustice is
that alpha made another prediction he
said if the Big Bang happened there
should have been a blast of radiation
that
company the Big Bang or several hundred
thousand years after Big Bang there
should been a blast of radiation that
was released and which would have filled
the entire universe and which should
still be here today if the Big Bang is
correct according to alpha this
radiation should still be with us today
and it should be here in the form of
microwaves and he said look go out and
look for the microwaves if you find them
the Big Bang is right if you don't find
them the Big Bang is wrong now
unfortunately nobody bothered looking
for the microwaves because people said
we don't have the technology and even if
we had the technology why should we
bother looking for evidence in favor of
a theory that we don't even believe in
so alpha was forgotten and it was only
in 1965 some 17 years after alphas
prediction that these two gentlemen mrs.
Arno Penzias on the right and Robert
Wilson on the left they were working
with a radio telescope really a large
radio detector which they weren't
pointing it the sky and stars and
galaxies and hydrogen clouds to measure
the radio waves and microwaves reform of
radio waves emitted from those celestial
objects but before they pointed their
telescope at the stars they pointed it
at empty space that's what you want to
do you wanna pointed at nothing and then
you can check that you see nothing you
can calibrate your detector check that
it's all working but when they pointed
it at nothing they got microwaves they
pointed it at another patch of the sky
they got microwaves they waited a day
still microwaves and they checked all
the wiring in case the wiring was
generating the microwaves the microwaves
are still there deep inside the throat
of the detector they found some pigeons
that were nesting and the pigeons had
deposited what they called a white
dielectric substance
so they got a pigeon trap they caught
the pigeons in the pigeon trap they took
them back to their offices about 20
miles away they release the pigeons
pigeons being pigeons just flew straight
back they caught them again in this
pigeon trap and they shot them they
cleaned out the white dielectric
substance still the microwaves were
there the microwaves just kept on coming
and eventually somebody tapped them on
the shoulder and said look what you've
discovered is the afterglow of the Big
Bang the radiation from the Big Bang and
it was exactly at the right wavelength
as alpha had predicted unfortunately as
I say alpha had been forgotten by this
stage and so when this story broke on
the front pages of the New York Times
and around the world
poorer alpha got no credit at all but
this this is really the clinching
evidence The Big Bang Theory made this
bold prediction of a radiation filling
the universe and you know when you go
out this evening that radiation those
microwaves come through the atmosphere
and they'll hit you on the head if you
tune your radio in between stations and
you hear that hissing sound one or two
percent of the energy that your aerial
is picking up is from those microwaves
from the Big Bang so this is really
compelling evidence that the Big Bang
really happened this is the pigeon trap
that they use to catch the pigeons and
it's actually here at the Smithsonian
Museum as part of an exhibition so a
momentous contribution to the history of
cosmology so I'm going to finish at this
point and hopefully we can cover things
that I've glossed over and missed in
question answers but I started off by
telling you the story of Sir James
Gene's and in 1930 he wrote a book to
try and explain what cosmologists 75
years ago understood about the universe
it was a popular account and that
Tallulah Bankhead read it and thoroughly
enjoyed it what I've tried to do is to
bring the story up to date know what do
today what do we know about the universe
and today what do we think about the
universe
now I'm nowhere near as eminent as Sir
James genes but my dream my ambition is
that one day Cameron Diaz will say
it contains what every girl should know
thank you very much
right I think I think this jet was was
first yes I understand what you said
about determining speed and direction
how did you get distance how do you
measure the distances the galaxies the
sensi I mean there's a light there in
the back of the auditorium now I don't
know is that a really bright light
that's a long way away or is it a dim
light that's close up and that's the
problem with measuring any distances in
the sky you don't know the brightness of
the objects you're measuring and
therefore you can't really work out how
far away they are Henrietta Leavitt to
work on Cepheid variables told her that
if a Cepheid very CLE then it's quite
dim if it varies slowly then it's quite
bright in fact she could actually put in
due course people could put hard numbers
between the periodicity and the absolute
brightness so then Hubble one day saw a
Cepheid variable in a galaxy he could
measure how quickly it varied that told
him exactly how bright it really was he
could see how bright it appeared to be
that allowed him to work out the
distance of the Cepheid and that allowed
him to work out the distance of the
galaxy now it turns out there are two
different types of sets and so Hubble
actually got it quite badly wrong in one
respect which is why he got the age of
the universe badly wrong
and and it's a very measuring distances
still remains quite a controversial area
but over the last 70 years the numbers
have become more and more accurate so
when we work at the age of the universe
today cosmologists you know when I was
an undergraduate I was told the universe
is 10 or 20 billion years old a factor
of 2 in the age range today the latest
numbers are 13.7 billion years so people
are you know giving it to one decimal
point which shows that maybe we're
entering a new era of precision
cosmology and the distance is one of the
crucial elements in trying to identify
that number yes
if hydrogen was fused into helium where
did hydrogen come from what you can do
and what you can do the one thing I
should say is that the the Big Bang
really happened you know no nothing as
science is an absolute 100% fact but as
much as we know anything the Big Bang
Theory is it isn't as a pretty
rock-solid theory there at want the
sense of cosmologists that's a number
I've made up but a small minority of
cosmologists disagree with it and that's
great because we should never get
complacent and it's good to have critics
who poke fun at these ideas and maybe
make us make these ideas stronger or
maybe one day undermine it who knows but
I think it's a rock-solid idea but it's
not complete there are some gaps in our
knowledge and you can run the clock
backwards from today's universe you can
run the clock back to the first hour
that's easy you can run the clock
backwards for the first minute after the
Big Bang trivial you could run the clock
backwards for the first billionth of a
billionth of a billionth of a second and
the physics is still pretty simple at
that stage you're probably looking at
quarks and gluons and the quarks and
gluons would have then merged into
protons and neutrons and that would have
formed hydrogen and then the hydrogen
were fused into helium before that
billionth of a billionth of a billionth
of a second that's where the physics
sort of breaks down and you start
entering the realm of speculation and
that doesn't be that doesn't mean people
will never know what happened at that
moment of creation or sort of what came
before the Big Bang which is maybe the
biggest question of all we don't know
there are no firm ideas at the moment
but it doesn't mean we'll never know I
think it was August the comped was a
French philosopher I think around 1830 I
think he said there are some things
we'll never ever know there are some
things which will always be beyond human
knowledge and on his list of things that
we will never know was what the stars
are made of he said that that's just
beyond human comprehension within ten
years of his death we knew what the
stars were made of
so today that
question of what happened at the moment
of creation seems impossible to answer
but people do do speculate about it and
maybe one day people will have an answer
maybe wait the judgment at the back yes
Big Bang Theory seems to imply that the
universe was created at a point or
singularity and that's sort of where the
physics breaks down one thing I should
clarify which may have been misleading
is that if all the matter in the
universe is running away from us then
you can trace it back to us so it looks
like we're standing roughly where the
Big Bang happened now what I might have
said that was misleading is might have
given you the impression that the
galaxies are racing away through space
they're not racing away through space
it's space that's expanding so so for
example if we look at this auditorium
now one way that we could move apart
from each other is for everybody to get
up and walk to the edge of the room now
we would then all be moving through
space but that's not what's happening
with the galaxies what's happening with
the galaxies is as I say space is
expanding so in that case that's a bit
like this auditorium suddenly doubling
in size the auditorium doubled in size
we would all move away from each other
now in that case I would look at
everybody here I've said gosh
everybody's moving away from me
but somebody at the back of the room
would say no everybody's moving away
from you you're in the middle of the
room you would see everybody moving away
from you so every galaxy in the universe
if you were sat on any galaxies in the
universe you would see all the other
galaxies moving away so everybody has
this sense that they're at the center of
the universe whereas in fact there isn't
really a center of the universe and
there would have been a single point of
creation yes yeah
and you just discussed the idea of
whether the expansion goes on forever
would eventually is a will the expansion
carry on forever again when I was an
undergraduate 20 years ago the idea was
it gravity would slow down the expansion
gravity pulls things back in so the
universe expands gravity slows down
expansion maybe halts it maybe even
pulls the universe back in on itself
maybe you're not ending the universe in
an almighty Big Crunch then in 1998
cosmologists astronomers noticed that in
fact the universe isn't slowing down
it's actually getting faster it's
accelerating the expansion of the
universe is accelerating and this was a
real shock and people are still only now
coming to terms with that I think there
have been enough observations to say yes
this really is the case the universe is
accelerating the theorists now have to
work out what's causing this
acceleration the effect is known as dark
energy
some kind of repulsive force but nobody
really understands the physics of that
and that's one of the great unsolved
problems so the fate of the universe of
the universe is certainly unknown at the
moment just trying to find yes Stefan
there
I had an oil explained the creation of
new matter
I think oil did did he attributed
something called the sea filled the
creation field and and he he came up
with some mathematics that sort of could
justify it but at the end of the day I
think he would have said look you guys
can't explain the creation at the moment
of the Big Bang which is someone off
freakish catastrophic event so let me
have some kind of continual creation and
we'll call it quits I think that was his
sort of argument but but but in when he
did his calculations for this he worked
out that the rate of creation of matter
was in order to to to explain the
universe he needed to create one atom
per century in a volume the size of the
Empire State Building so he was saying
don't expect to point your telescopes up
into space and see galaxies appear from
nowhere this rate of creation is so slow
that you know we'll never observe it so
again he could say that his theory was
consistent with observation which was a
very important point yes
can you make friends yes what you then
the missing step that I haven't
explained is how you measure the
distance to anyone set it once you know
the distance to one Cepheid you can work
out the distances to all the others
Henrietta didn't complete that step that
was left to other people and in one of
the ways for example you measured the
distance people couldn't measure the
distances to the Stars I think until
about 1700s the way you want to measure
things if I wanted to measure it but I
can estimate the distance to people here
in this room
by using my stereoscopic vision I can
say well this one is is is pointing in
that direction to the Jasmine and back
this eyes pointing in a slightly
different direction and by seeing where
my directions of sign me to I can
estimate distance if I if I bring my
finger up to closer to my eye my eyes
are kind of crossing there and I can
work out my fingers just a few inches
away so having two points at which you
can make observations allows you to
triangulate gives you stereoscopic
vision and as humans we can work out
distance that way what astronomers
wanted to do is say well up
sometimes the earth is here this is the
Sun sometimes the earth is here and
sometimes the earth is there so
astronomers make observations from two
very very different distances the
distance in the Sun is 150 million
million miles I think I've got that
right
so therefore you move double that
distance and therefore you can
triangulate the distances to the stars
so that's how you get the very first
distances to the Stars and then there
are various other techniques which I
kind of brush under the rug and move on
very quickly cuz I'm not sure what those
are but eventually we get to Henrietta
Leavitt cepheid's yes jasmine there
30:20 the big yes I mean I've missed
that a lot of people in this talk a lot
of contributions from various people I
do talk about Alexandra Friedman in in
the book Friedman was a cosmologists
working in Russia in the mid 1920s and
he liked George Lemaitre said according
to the laws of physics there's no reason
why the universe couldn't have started
as a big bang he then wrote a letter to
he wrote a paper I think and Einstein
said look your maths is wrong you've got
it wrong and Lamech said no no sorry
Friedman said no I think I've got it
right and I Stan had to apologize
but Einstein still didn't believe that
this theory was correct and the tragedy
with Friedman has really died very young
he died I think of pneumonia so he
didn't get to see his ideas vindicated
in the same way la murtra did he it
would have been actually very difficult
for him because because he lived and
worked in the Soviet Union
the Soviets hated the idea of the Big
Bang because they saw the Big Bang as
implying a creator and they saw it as a
sort of a religious theory clearly
scientific theories shouldn't involve
religion of any kind but according to
communist communist hated the idea of
relativity they hated the idea of the
Big Bang and cosmologists in in Soviet
Union who backed the Big Bang Theory
were often persecuted for their beliefs
so it's difficult to know what would
have happened to someone like Friedman
in in the years had he survived
yes judgment over the blue shirt
okay so how do we had what's happening
to Andromeda Andromeda is another galaxy
one of our nearby neighboring galaxies
and it's moving towards us is that a
problem I mean the gentleman earlier was
asking about the fate of the universe
and if the universe expands forever and
runs away with itself then as the
universe gets bigger and bigger energy
will get more and more spread out matter
will get more and more spread out the
universe will become unbearably desolate
and lifeless so there will be a point
where life will not be able to exist
anywhere but we don't need to worry
about that because long before that
happens Andromeda will crash into our
galaxy and probably erase all forms of
life anyway and well before that happens
I think the Sun is going to enlarge into
some kind of red giant or something and
swallow up Mercury and Venus and Earth
and Mars anyway so again there's no real
reason to worry about Andromeda yes if
there yes I I think maybe just the lady
there and the judgment here at the front
yes sorry if there are more than 10
dimensions and there are parallel
universes did they all begin with a big
bang I think yeah I think I think the
issue of parallel universes are very
interesting because again I think it's
important to differentiate between
cosmology where people really have hard
evidence and cosmology which is sort of
flights of fancy but who knows one day
we'll have might have the evidence to
prove those as well the idea is that
maybe our universe could give birth to
another universe maybe our universe was
born from our parent universe she had
this family tree of universes and they
all come under together under the banner
of the multiverse and each universe
would be slightly different from its
parent each will be slightly mutated and
people like the idea of the multiverse
because we have life in our universe and
that's some really quite miraculous
extraordinary because if gravity had
been different in our universe and it
could have been different if gravity had
been stronger then the Stars would have
been denser and they'd have burned more
quickly and they'd have burned so
quickly that life wouldn't have had time
to evolve if gravity had been weaker
then the Stars wouldn't have formed in
the first place and life couldn't have
evolved so gravity is not too strong not
not too weak just right as a Goldilocks
gravity just right for life and it's not
just gravity it's electric force the
nuclear force strong and weak they're
all just tuned for life it seems and
religious people might say that's
because there's a tuner somebody
carefully tuned the dials so that life
could could evolve multiverse proponents
would say well look if they're an
infinite number of universes and they're
all slightly different most of them will
be sterile and have no life and may
collapse instantaneously after they're
created but some of them will be just
right for life and we obviously live in
one of those universes because we
couldn't live anywhere else so the idea
of a parallel universes and multiverses
is is very attractive and there was a
lady that back maybe the last question
necessarily just water
I didn't quite catch it but I think what
we say is is the Big Bang a one-off
event or could it happen several times
you know again when I was an
undergraduate people quite fond of the
idea of a big bang expansion slowdown
collapse big crunch
big rebound another big bang and so on
with everything being erased in in the
big rebound moment now that seems to
being compatible with the idea of a
universe that's accelerating and racing
away because then there doesn't seem to
be any hope for for a Big Crunch and
then another Big Bang but I think Neil
Turok who who is a very eminent
cosmologists he's arguing at the moment
I think that the acceleration phase that
were going through at the moment may
only be temporary and that the universe
may then slow down and then it may stop
and then it may end up in another Big
Crunch then another Big Bang so I it's
it's sort of in the realm of speculation
and just one last thing I maybe I'll
finish with with Neil Turok
Neil Turok the very first time I ever
spoke about the Big Bang was in
Edinburgh at a book festival in
Edinburgh and as soon as I finished
speaking a lady on the back row who
turned out to be Neil Turok
schoolteacher when he was a little boy
he's very eminent cosmologists today but
she'd obviously taught him very well
when he was young and she put her hand
up in the back and she said what went
bang you know what came before the Big
Bang similar to the gentleman's question
in the very beginning and I explained to
her I tried to answer her question what
came before the Big Bang and I talked
about multiverse is and I talked about
big Crunch's and big bands and then I
said maybe the best way to answer your
question is to give an analogy with st.
Augustine because st. Augustine was
asked a similar question theologically
he was asked what was God doing before
he created the universe which is the
theological equivalent of what happened
before the Big Bang and when I say to
Augustine was asked what was God doing
before he created the universe he
replied by saying
he was creating hell for people who
asked questions like you so maybe that's
it's a very very fair question
but a difficult one to answer but thank
you very very much for listening thank
you